is a quiet indigenous community in
Mexico's quintanaro state the town is
well known for their traditional mine
embroideries
mostly what we do is all hand
embroidered using a counter thread
technique this region of Mexico is one
of the poorest in the country
the word of a new Railway project coming
through town has many here hopeful the
local economy could soon be put on the
right track
we're hoping to take advantage of the
Mayan train to produce and sell many
more of our embroideries
but not everyone is on board with the
new Railway dubbed then Maya or Maya
train in Spanish
and it's not difficult to see why
much of the space that's been carved out
for the 20 billion dollar project Cuts
right through the jungle walking along
this construction site you can clearly
see the way the rainforest has been
split into but this massive
infrastructure project has also divided
opinion here in Mexico
Mexican authorities say the railway
could lift more than a million people
out of poverty and generate more than
700 000 new jobs by the end of the
decade
but indigenous activists like Angel
sulub say what they see is a scar across
the rainforest landscape
this project brings destruction not only
to nature but also to the social fabric
the government's argument is job
creation but we have to look at it in a
deeper way in order to appreciate the
real impact it will have on the Mayan
people
the Maya train was thought up by Mexican
president Andres Manuel Lopez obrador
who promised a state-of-the-art Scenic
Railway to boost tourism
and the promise of an economic boom for
some of the poorest communities in the
country
despite concerns from environmentalists
indigenous activists and even
archaeologists completion of the Mayan
train is scheduled for the end of this
year
but it won't end the arguments in
developing nations like Mexico about
striking a balance between economic
development and social responsibility
Mexico
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera